justo cuando muchos países europeos
volvían a la normalidad y después de
levantar restricciones el verano pasado
una nueva ola de contagios sorprende al
viejo continente en países bajos en las
últimas 24 horas se registraron más de
16.300 nuevos contagios el dato más alto
desde el inicio de la pandemia y que ha
generado presión en el sistema
hospitalario del país ya
se han aumentado las pruebas en las
últimas semanas al principio vimos un
leve incremento y nos anticipamos
colocando otra unidad para realizar más
pruebas y día a día fue creciendo
navistar ahora comenzamos con la agenda
completa mucha gente viene sin cita
porque quiere realizarse la prueba pero
ya no tenemos disponibilidad de berlín
el pasado 2 de noviembre ante el rebrote
el primer ministro mark rutte anunció el
regreso de algunas restricciones como el
uso obligatorio de mascarillas en
espacios cerrados a partir del 6 de
noviembre las autoridades llamaron a una
reunión de emergencia cuyas conclusiones
podrían darse a conocer este viernes el
temor a un confinamiento parcial está
latente entre los ciudadanos que se
muestran pesimistas y consternados
siento que se pondrá peor todo muy
pronto pero estaba cansado de trabajar
en casa sentado en el ático detrás de mi
computador así que no estoy esperando un
nuevo bloqueo me temo que no tuvo ningún
logrado en el proyecto según el conteo
independiente de world in that a países
bajos cuenta con el 68 9% de su
población de unos 17 5 millones de
habitantes completamente vacunada pero
no escapa a la ola de contagios que
afecta a europa que según la
organización mundial de la salud es la
única región en el mundo donde los casos
han mostrado un aumento constante en las
últimas semanas